[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] to that.
Also I'm sounding as Capcom's a tank that at least, I mean,
park on fire, the cross-team for
[inaudible] their tank, her [inaudible].
Um.
[Inaudible] five 48. Let's give it 10 in book. So
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] is done and familiar [inaudible] of meat
Well, or,
but for Claudia that you do do I sung
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, D eh [inaudible] uh,
eh, [inaudible] [inaudible]
VAR [inaudible].
Yeah. Or the VOD Oxo. We into border E mean mamas,
Vieta of a middle class familiars done Oxo.
You mean false, uh, sparked our better class, familiar Harlem
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] their alarm that Tilden our dog.
So ideally some mango in a [inaudible] melon,
swath of eight melon from
[inaudible] when a Devo, you did the soaks you,
so they can set some out to Seville order them in
little spoon, like some
[inaudible] at a
[inaudible] they are sad and meth hair [inaudible] mentally
and or special door for sex. Dettol I mean, far more
[inaudible] at [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible], uh, comma Avodah, uh, or, uh, uh, [inaudible].
They'll divide [inaudible] so,
uh [inaudible].
Yeah, proceed so fairly to market. I can't the, or Snyder,
like some [inaudible]. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
Your couldn't spend there that long teed
[inaudible] to have as a high,
had the twins on the Veet when we have a
[inaudible] pass out in a hurry, avoid VACCA, um,
or Tang out the farms here in small, mainly
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] uh, uh, loud mail [inaudible] um,
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible].
Yeah, also a high sister and still got sister, some, uh,
health [inaudible] or communities to some of it.
[inaudible] men. Your for,
for me some lead and hello in ortho and Neo [inaudible]
believe, uh,
Paul mean via door or
[inaudible] [inaudible] so [inaudible] et cetera. Uh,
some, uh, uh,
[inaudible] uh, health
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
[inaudible] uh,
he still leave her champagne, some health
[inaudible] food. Commonly Dell
[inaudible] hell it's faster. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] yes. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] couldn't thank him. Um.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, exactly. Men and soccer. Who protector vol
Devonna. U-Tech the heat Pope and Somia Oxo bird. The se then how
[inaudible], uh, some normal things. Some
[inaudible] Passau in Eden had VAT and smell.
So young Villa in a really, so young of all,
some of them have rap and I also have poor yo MTV raps. So last on me,
he hip hop connection. Uh,
[inaudible] New York, but clam, I forgot a
[inaudible] TV, stale food from the end he dog,
he popped him back in to
[inaudible] put a set that I think guide other and
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] who also good Tila fact is lad.
I may up Eliska Julio. So good.
[inaudible] is not for hip-hop as we don't find that eating and team [inaudible]
team.
[Inaudible] uh, so, so,
so other than [inaudible] South Carolina,
we fully it.
Your Villa de flat
[inaudible] [inaudible] did some slavery yet, or
[inaudible] who set the potato,
but last on the bucket of hell, I'm at leave. When Ali hit the chant powder.
[Inaudible].
It's only if I felt the old after slavery at me, your bothersome, uh,
[inaudible] some dog
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] man.
May you see South Carolina?
[inaudible] [inaudible] so we've
[inaudible] on a bill can handle it on [inaudible],
uh, [inaudible] extreme classes, this thing, and plots for, uh, listen,
Sparta tank and many who see I'll take a darker date when it mean blue will
best event and semen closer. Sorry.
[inaudible] but they had no one to [inaudible] and so we flew you get to
Charleston [inaudible] so I said,
[inaudible] shove in, not land that is South Carolina,
or since another group saying gun, this Oh, cook,
or they felt stuck on me.
I said that boomers felt that doesn't involve in our firefighters.
Valda Darrell. There does leave Aveda murder roots,
Baylor to say Boda Dallas [inaudible] blurred monoxide. Doug
[inaudible] you had a poem at Paul's a ladder skill, listen,
Poots are the
[inaudible] [inaudible] at or leaks from Springer
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] Placa all of them have small boomers to Sana
[inaudible] American home book for me. It's keyboard. So I'll take
[inaudible] and Butler.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] the special gloss books.
[inaudible] they
[inaudible] they take the hon vol yum for bots, our town, uh,
or men
[inaudible] smacked some poem in it's a
[inaudible] not so it's so blue, tall economic system, eh,
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] uh,
Sophie instill, uh [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible], uh, VU. Don't
eat dogs, some oxygen [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] in fact it's so sad unless they're going on a
[inaudible] fan or that put up and got the ball,
he turns by E you know how to spell that port.
And from this festivals meant to slots, field festival and some Paul
[inaudible] and
[inaudible] boost fat. And
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] uh
[inaudible] or there was a link sent a catalog this day.
[inaudible] uh, so, uh, let's get
[inaudible] at, and [inaudible] eh, men
[inaudible] book, uh.
[Inaudible].
You said
[inaudible] upload the funnel somehow and somehow get this a day. Uh,
uh, they at, uh,
this gambling [inaudible] we
[inaudible] Los mono that's right after I had a cast at Humber and the ancestor
poem, uh [inaudible] and all that, that,
uh, uh, [inaudible] uh,
or Slack smart menu.
[inaudible] [inaudible] um,
[inaudible] how did the hell love volleyball? They intercept that, that, uh,
Burma are not on tower. You have a log. So to work,
most of the store I've known some say are salty,
and I'm on many quite into vet bottom yard.
[inaudible] [inaudible] the most money [inaudible].
Do HIO, uh,
for shirked or [inaudible]. Uh,
[inaudible] uh, [inaudible] uh,
hard findings. Nice sauce. [inaudible] hi.
[inaudible] [inaudible] hello.
I asked them at [inaudible] things,
and then I built kind of first, may I say, you know, may
[inaudible] new [inaudible] them,
so [inaudible] wow. In the ILA lead the soul, man.
Um, since sham, the Romney works at autumn,
[inaudible] puts out some dumb into Vos, PCL, big family,
man Mandela, the telltale fake after the mung, a telephone,
some tall make a tall, uh, emails. Uh,
so Okta net is going to have that some tall Madam
[inaudible] let me mama [inaudible] for cloth. I felt on VAR, uh,
Val [inaudible] [inaudible] of mean
[inaudible] to me in Papa, I thought I taught [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and we have,
there are some taller totem list. Not upon me. Well, they've all new
[inaudible] left med, uh, Mami, and I forgot Ella
[inaudible] man, for me, [inaudible]
for holding space. Theodore Southtown at that fact is [inaudible].
[Inaudible].